tre is with us in Manchester New
Hampshire hi Trey how are you uh I'm
better than I deserve
about you just the same how can I help
um I'm trying to decide whether I need
to get out of a variable annuity account
okay why did you get in it uh because I
uh I was referring to this guy by a
friend of mine and he put me into this
account about ten years ago why did you
get into it well because I thought it
was a good idea at the time
okay what was what was a good idea what
part of it was a good idea um the part
that I felt was good that it was a you
know that it was going to grow at a
certain rate and there wasn't a lot of
risk involved okay all right
you mean a minimum amount of right yeah
it's a if it's a variable annuity by
definition its variable but variable
Nerys have a evident some of them have a
rate of growth guaranteed as a minimum
of growth right right well this has like
a every three years it has like a
step-up yep so it has like a current you
know I can look in my account at the
current income base but the cash the
render value is the exact same is when I
put the money in okay so it's invested
poorly inside of there inside of a
variable annuity or mutual funds that
you can choose and what you're saying is
is they haven't grown correct okay and
well what I would do is get it back in
touch with whoever your broker is you
should have done this a while back
probably and see if you don't you can
change your mix inside of there you
don't have to stay in the exact same
funds right and choose better funds if
you can't find funds inside of the
variable annuity that have good
long-term track records that would have
outperformed the S&P as an example then
I would look at rolling that variable
annuity over to a different variable
annuity a different brand that would
have
mutual funds in it that are actually
doing well that you can pick from there
are several that have done well the
biggest problem just not a big fan of
variable annuities and the reason
they're sold most often is because the
Commission's are about four times as
much on that as they are on a
traditional mutual fund purchase yes but
if you take the money out you've been in
it if you've been in a pastor surrender
charge point where yeah well anyway yes
I'm past the surrender okay all right so
you'll just have taxes on the growth in
what you're saying is there ever been
any right well if I take it out today
I basically take out what I put in yeah
if because this is my this was a pension
and this was my um you know my IRA yeah
Howry 47 okay well I I am NOT a fan of
the variable annuity products because
the fees or so heavy it said so yeah
there are good mutual funds out there
that you could have been in and
obviously you would have made more but
you wouldn't have had the guarantee do
you own a home yeah okay you didn't get
a guarantee when you bought that correct
and what you're looking for is a mutual
fund that feels more like a home than
trading stocks meaning that it's an old
moss-covered
growth stock mutual fund that's got a
long track record and therefore you've
got a lot more comfort in it like you're
buying a home in a good neighborhood
even though you don't have a quote
unquote downside guarantee the you know
what you're getting you didn't have a
downside guarantee on the house but your
guarantee was the track record of the
neighborhood you bought in you feel good
enough about the client the investment
class of real estate single-family real
estate and then you looked at the
particular neighborhood you're in and
went oh this is going to be okay I'm not
going to you know it might go down but
if I just don't sell it it'll be okay
over time and that's what you look at
with a good mutual-fund so what I would
tell you is get in touch with one of our
endorsed local providers LPS sit down
with them if you don't have someone
already in the business that you trust
and that they'll sit down with you with
the heart of a teacher because the
reason I was asking the questions is I
want to make sure you put money in
something because you understood it and
don't ever use the phrase again so and
so put me in some
no you put you in something you make the
decision and once your brokers job your
advisors job is to advise and then you
make the decision I want you to
understand what you're putting money
into that's the big thing and if you do
that you're going to be okay so I would
either roll it to another variable
annuity or I just straight-up cash it
out and just move it into some good
growth stock mutual funds straight up
something that's simple and you can get
again get in touch with one of the LPS
and they'll help you you may want to
look at some no loads or even some and
you can do those on a managed account
with these guys it's not any problem to
do that at all I'm not against that
where they just charge you a fee to
manage the portfolio and then you can
look at it with them and decide but what
reason I said you might want to do some
no loads or some is because you probably
want to put some some index funds in the
mix that have a low turnover ratio
because if this thing starts making a
profit you're going to get taxed on it
if it's not inside of that annuity if
you buy open fund open market mutual
funds but the good news is if you buy
low turnover mutual funds that means
that the income is not taxable because
they haven't sold the stocks inside the
mutual fund very often and it's not
taxable until you pull it out and when
you do pull it out the money that you
make on it is taxed at capital gains
rate where if it's in a variable annuity
and it goes way up and then you pull it
out that's going to be taxed at ordinary
income rate so I love low turnover
mutual funds in a setting like we're
like you and I are talking about here
now that's outside of normal retirement
this is not in an IRA if this is in an
IRA I just rolled it into some you know
the mix we always talk about always
spread my personal my personal
investments across four types growth
growth and income aggressive growth and
international hey thanks for the call
man appreciate you joining us
several people tweeting this week Warren
Buffett talking about just buy an S&P
500 fund put it in a Roth IRA and forget
it you could do that and it really
wouldn't be a bad idea
although you could hello why do you say
that oh yeah I mean you could do that
but but I mean that's just buying the
average that's all you're doing
that's called passive investing
and if you've been listening to show for
about 30 seconds you know I'm not
passive about hardly anything and that
would include my investing so my
personal 401k has outperformed the SP
net of fees after all commissions and
expenses and everything are paid by over
one and a half points a year for the
past decade notice I made a percent and
a half more than you would have made if
you followed Orrin Buffett and let me
just a percent and a half is a lot a lot
but I a lot of mutual funds do not
outperform the S&P so you never want to
buy a mutual fund unless it's
outperforming the S&P and you can look
right there on the website of the mutual
fund and it's got a trendline on it it
shows if it has outperformed the S&P and
so if you're not going to do if you're
going to buy a mutual fund this that
will be dumb that's less than the S&P
then do what Buffett says do passive
investing but you know the only thing
I've got against that is I think you can
do better by not being passive how about
being active in your life you know and
but he's just giving advice to dumb down
where people don't have to think and I
just want to encourage you to think
there you go this is the Dave Ramsey
show hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show and so you have to break the
cycle you have to flip this thing on its
head and make it behave you've got to
get so fired up and wired up that you're
broke friends think you've lost your
mind
you